Hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna be my breakdown of the leaked Avengers what if trailer footage from d23
I've talked a little bit about the series before so we'll break it all down
We have a whole bunch of new details and we're doing a new round of the Disney Plus
Streaming service giveaway, all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your favorite
What if story on the video? What do you want them to do? What if Wolverine fought Thanos during Avengers endgame
What if general Ross became the Red Hulk instead of Bruce Banner?
Becoming the green version of the Hulk we got information on about six episodes
Including what's going on with spider-man during the series?
They'll be 23 episodes total one for each of the movies in the MCU so far
So that includes spider-man homecoming in spider-man far from home as well as using
Spider-man in the ones that they do for Avengers infinity war and Avengers end game and Captain America Civil War
The whole idea is that you have the watcher narrating the series the same way that he narrates a lot of Marvel Comics Marvel
What-if is a long-running comic series. Jeffrey Wright is gonna be there watcher. They announced him at the Comic Con panel
He'll be narrating all the episodes as the main version of The Watcher in every once in a while
He'll step out of the shadows to interact with the characters in the episodes
Maybe not every single episode because it's really special and really rare that the watcher ever
speaks to any of the Marvel characters
It's actually been a while since that's happened in the comics if you're a longtime fan of agents of shield
They did an episode inspired by the Marvel. What-if series where they all got stuck inside this mainframe and live this alternate reality
within the computer mainframe
But technically it wasn't a real what-if story because it was all happening inside a simulation instead of actually happening to the characters in
Reality, so breaking down the six episodes that we had footage for number six the Black Panther episode
What if Black Panther became star-lord?
Technically it would be what if T'Challa became star-lord because I think in this scenario just looking at the footage here
He's wearing star Lords uniform
He's probably not also wearing the mantle of Black Panther during this scenario
Because this would be a situation where his father winds up being ego the Living Planet. He visits earth
His mother is still from Wakanda, but then you have to imagine him during the plot of the original guardians of the galaxy movie
Where you have the route?
Coming to pick up a young version of Peter quill take him to space and he grows up with the Ravagers
So you have a version of T'Challa black panther growing up with the Ravagers. He's wearing star-lords helmet
It looks like he's on Morag here at the beginning of the events of the first guardians of the galaxy movie to steal the Power
Stone so that sounds wildly different but because it's a black panther episode kill monger is also coming back and starring in it
Meaning that if Black Panther wasn't there to become Black Panther during the events of the Black Panther movie
That means the kill monger is probably able to come back take the mantle seize
Wakanda and then use their vibranium to take over the world
Just like his plan was during the Black Panther movie
Even though all the what-if stories don't always have a downer ending that does sound like a bit of a downer ending for planet Earth
Darkest timeline earth even while star-lord touch ala is playing around in the Stars having fun with the guardians of the galaxy
Team a lot of you also noticed that the animation style looks very similar to the animation style on Iron Man armored adventures
But that cel-shaded animation. I think this is going to be a little bit more premium than that
Number 5 there's a Captain America First Avenger episode, I believe that's even supposed to be the very first episode of the series
What if Peggy Carter got the Super Soldier Serum and became?
Captain America our version of Captain America in what if skinny Steve Rogers got a big Ironman suit designed by Howard Stark
They're bringing back young Howard Stark Arnim Zola. Dr. Erskine for that episode. This is all going to be half hour animation
So you have to imagine them condensing the plot of Captain America First Avenger into a half hour episode
So the first little bit of the episode plays almost exactly like the events of the first Captain America movie
She's the one that goes into the device gets the Super Soldier Serum
But when she comes out because she's British they call her Captain Britain. She wears the Captain Britain comic book costume
Remember there was a Captain Britain Easter egg during Avengers end game during the Peggy Carter
1970s scene she mentions an agent Braddock Braddock is Captain Britain in the comics
So even though the what-if series is sort of like an else world story
Like what if things were different technically not canon to the MCU within the actual real cannon of the MCU?
There was the captain Britain. We just don't know what he was doing running around during the 1970s, but this is trailer footage
From what it's actually going to look like during this series
So like you see skinny Rogers in this giant Iron Monger tank looking Iron Man suit is world war two
so
Of course
the suit would look like an actual tank because Howard Stark probably just
Repurposes an actual tank to make the suit the rest of the episode plays out very similar to what the plot of the original
Captain America movie was although I don't know if they're gonna get Hugo Weaving to come back because remember Ross
Marquand is now the new version of Red Skull inside the MCU
Because Hugo Weaving did not want to come back in Avengers infinity war in Avengers endgame
They didn't say why so entertain whatever conspiracy theory you want
Maybe he just didn't want to do Red Skull anymore
But we do have a version of Red Skull and Ross mark and he's mostly known from The Walking Dead
So he does a lot of TV
I think it's pretty easy to get him to come back to do more red skull inside the what-if series the
Showrunners of the what-if series actually did an interview at d23 talking a little bit about the dynamic of what's going on during these episodes
The most surprising thing for a lot of the actors has been they're getting to play
Aspects of their characters that they would never get to do in the MCU
And even though we just talked about a guardians of the galaxy black panther episode number four because there's one for every single MCU movie
There is a what-if episode for both guardians of the galaxy movies with number four Thanos coming back
Fragglan Korra Theon do taser faces coming back
So that's probably a version of events where ego the Living Planet
might be
Successful because the whole idea is that Peter quill is able to stand against his father and say no I'm gonna stay with the family
That I made for myself not the family that I was born with
Imagine a version of Peter quill that completely embraced his cosmic abilities and his celestial heritage
I know that a lot of questions about how those worked and why he didn't use his powers later the whole idea
Is that being half celestial gives him a vastly expanded lifespan even without cosmic powers. He still will live longer
He won't get sick like other people
but the closer he gets to ego the Living Planet the more
Powerful, he gets he was at his most powerful when they were standing right next to his brain
So because ego died or seemingly died during that movie because there's a question of whether or not you can actually really kill him
All of Peter Quill's greater celestial abilities basically went away
So he seems more like a normal person but 50% of his DNA is still celestial so he still will live longer than normal humans
3 there's a Thor episode Loki Thor Korg the Grand Master and Jane Foster Nick Fury are coming back
Because all these Marvel phase 4 TV shows are meant to crossover and set up what's going on in the movies
I assumed that the Thor episode is just meant to set up the
concept of Jane Foster Thor from an alternate reality or whether it's going to be Jane Foster in our
Reality that wields the hammer
They haven't really been clear about that because technically there is no Mjolnir in the main universe of the MCU right now
They took the one that they had during endgame back to Thor the dark world. So there is no Mjolnir in present day
So the only way you get Mjolnir in present day is if Loki from the alternate reality brings one in traveling from that place
But they haven't said much about what's going on with hella or whether or not Kate Blanchet is going to come back
She did say that she wants to come back
but if there's gonna be 23 episodes then the
20-something MCU actors that they announced publicly at comic-con are probably just a fraction of the actual
MCU actors that will be coming to do the episodes the series is going to premiere summer
2021 and we get Thor for love and thunder that November so they might just double up on episodes
They've done it for a lot of other animated series in the past where they released a block of episodes
Every single week instead of just one episode - we know about the ant-man episode
They didn't say whether it's ant-man the wasp or it's the original ant-man movie
But ant-man Hank Pym in the ex-con team are coming back. Like what if they had gotten stuck in the quantum realm?
What if Hank Pym had continued to wear the ant-man suit instead of passing it off to Scott Lang in the first movie?
What if Janet Van Dyne had come out of the quantum realm sooner what if hope had warned the ant-man suit during the events of?
The first movie because it's animation
I also expect them to get into way more quantum realm stuff because it's way cheaper
For them to do those crazy special effects when they're animating it
But probably the biggest episode that they leaked trailer footage of is number one Marvel Zombies
You see the scene of Winter Soldier in present day getting ready to fight zombie Captain
America if you're not a big comic book fan or you're not familiar with the concept of Marvel Zombies
That's dori from Marvel Comics done by Robert Kirkman of walking dead faint big surprise. He does zombies stories
He does a Marvel Zombies
Story where zombie Reed Richards tricks his ultimate universe
Counterpart Reed Richards into opening a portal to the zombie universe or the reality where everyone has become a zombie
allowing them into the ultimate
Universe after which you can guess what happened all the zombies start consuming all the regular versions of the characters in the Ultimate Universe
meanwhile zombies decide that the flesh of other zombies isn't just as satisfying so Galactus shows up because this is a big
Fantastic Four story eventually, the zombies are able to wear him down consume him steal his lifeforce
Empowering them with cosmic level abilities. They set out to the Stars to Galactus style consume
Everything in sight because the series isn't coming for a couple years
It is possible for them to use Fantastic Four x-men
Mutant concepts during this and while I was making my spider-man video yesterday
It was actually discovered
That the reason why Marvel can still use spider-man in this series is because Marvel has the TV rights for half-hour
animation
That's why most of the spider-man TV series so far have come from Marvel and not from Sony
So because all these what-if episodes are half-hour animation, they can do whatever they want to with spider-man
I don't know if they're allowed to use Tom Holland though
Or if that signed a new contract for that or get another actor to be the voice of spider-man in these episodes the same way
That they got Ross mark and to be the red skull during Avengers infinity war and Avengers endgame the very first Marvel phase 4 series
That's gonna drop will be Falcon in Winter Soldier and that'll be next fall
Not this year, but next year the what-if series is gonna drop summer 2021
So we'll probably get some more footage at Comic Con next year. Maybe some other stuff will leak out before then
If it does I will totally do a video for it, but let me know in the comments which what-if stories
Do you want them to do and the ideas that they'll continue to do new episodes?
So when we get the Marvel phase 4 movies Marvel phase 5 phase 6
They'll do new seasons of what-if with episodes for each of those brand new movies
There's a couple new Marvel videos that I'm working on while you guys wait for that
You can click here for my non-spoilery joker movie review and you can click here for my breakdown of that
Fantastic Four Comic Con Teezer. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight